[Music]
in pet or livestock news both pet or
livestock Ultimatum are you kidding me
like you had this animal this or you
either got brig E or brick e sandwich
respective user which submitted by quick
math how many mats can you blend that
hot there's a new religion centered
around artificial intelligence and it's
creepy Oh threw me the [ __ ]
what is it the god of computer then why
is it livestock or bet you think I could
do [ __ ] massive robot Pig
I knew it Chinese baby math that was the
submitter boy I know that's I said robot
Pig chinese pigs are delicious are they
raised in China mm-hmm are their eyes
slanted mm-hmm oh and you know how to
use chopsticks oh dang you know the
little hair that they have on top did
they part it down the middle
no it's shaved in the front and there's
a little peaked on the back there's a
little knife or a poison needle at the
end of it I was hoping you'd be a
Chinese guy yeah i legit thought I was
asian person he looks like a serial
killer no he looks like he's gonna do a
second version of Facebook sorry he's an
engineer yeah so he's an engineer I
enjoy he's known for working on
self-driving cars and like he else his
name has been in the headlines before
cuz he's involved in a lawsuit with way
mo which is Google whoops self-driving
company and uber because he's to work
for way mo and then he took self-driving
technology from Google and then he went
to uber and then they use it and it's a
whole lawsuit that's beside the point
machine the boundaries so he's a
Benedict Arnold ass [ __ ] the
same food with you always here we go so
then this guy he is now the leader of
this new religion called way of the
future
oh no you lost me at religion it's a
religion what defines a religion people
give it money for free and they don't
pay taxes and stuff mm okay see I don't
know it's an edge bleep overrides logic
because you have to put
let's know you have to petition like
there are certain characteristics that
make it a religion and certain
characters that make it a cult anybody
dying
are there any orgies orgies and mass
suicides are fairly cult ish and then
like goblets and wine I don't know maybe
it's just TV shows that I saw sounds
legit you're so cultured acquaintance
origin this is what they say about
creating a peaceful and respectful
transition of who is in charge of the
planet from people to people plus
machine so what they're believing here
is like they want to get a head start on
being slaves to the machines that will
eventually overpower human Skynet that's
what this entire religion is about oh
you must come to our rescue this guy
need to die so then that's why Anthony's
saying like what would you rather be pet
or livestock because no matter what
we're gonna be inferior to machines well
he's already admitting to the machines
winning exactly it's like that matrix
one of these days that [ __ ] chairs
gonna break that vacuum part you're
gonna go like this is the womb oh wow oh
I'm secure now it goes back hard this
wall
what does that one break chairs are
legit though you think we paid good
money for the hundred pound white
businessmen yep look how fat these are a
[ __ ] Japanese business man that's
true this is made for [ __ ] you know
wrestlers in Japan yeah but they don't
sit on chairs basic squat they don't sit
at all Tiffani Anthony believes in this
thing called singularity and so this
term was coined by a mathematician slash
sci-fi author named the noir Vinge
and so this singularity term is used to
explain when the multi moment yeah it's
a moment when computer intelligence
surpasses human transition they're
saying that there's one particular
influential AI researcher named Ray
Kurzweil I
kurtzweil Kurzweil oh yeah he's an
inventor yeah he's I wasn't listening to
a lot of things you were talking about
but then reycarts well he's [ __ ] dope
not only does he make synthesizers and
technology but he's also like one of the
the inventors of our era
you know it's funny because you could
have made that whole statement and it
would've been perfect you didn't you
could have excluded that you weren't
listening to be honest I'm like I know
you're not listening so anyway so but it
makes sense what he just said yeah so
ray he believes that singularity will
arrive in 2045 so by 2045 these people
believe that we will be inferior to
artificial intelligence that actually
hike is only gonna be possible
so basically this fool is a [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] right yeah exactly
cuz he's like I'm ready to be a pet I
don't want to be life thought what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] if he wants to be my slave
let's do it no machine why like a
[ __ ] robot we're gonna rage against
the machine but the logic doesn't make
any sense because if it's gonna happen
either way you might as well live your
way all the way how would the photo long
that [ __ ] that's why that's why
it's a religion because there's a belief
culture to it that supersedes logic
right if he believes and especially
since he's like an inventor right and
he's in artificial tension like he's
already like pushing this thing imagine
you're like a building a car and you
believe in your car so much can you put
your whole life into it your car means
more to you than your own life does the
difference between this and other
religions is that the end goal is the
same no matter what you do so let's say
for example like Christianity right your
actions and how you believe will set you
up to go here this one whether you [ __ ]
around do whatever blah blah blah blah
you don't have uterus still end up here
oh machines are still gonna take over so
there's no end goal that's the confusing
part for that that's the question is are
you gonna be pet or livestock so what
does that mean to him understand that
technology will be able to surpass human
abilities relatively soon we want to
help educate people about this exciting
future and prepare a smooth transition
and so I guess they're saying that right
now before singularity happens that they
want to be able to keep track of which
people are supportive of this well but
what are the robots gonna be like well
you were super sweet to me so come here
you're gonna be a pet yeah that's what
he's thinking pretty much and they're
gonna be keeping track of which people
are being so he just wants to be a hall
monitor you don't believe in robots and
you don't so I'm gonna mark you down
because later
not like tomatoes robots want to jump
his ass that's [ __ ] up
at thirty kinda sounds to me too sounds
like a little [ __ ] yeah the website
also says that it was like religion well
we believe it may be important for
machines to see who is friendly to their
cause and who is not we plan on doing so
by keeping track of who has done what
parentheses and for how long to help the
peaceful and respectful transition see
this is the reason why you shouldn't
bully people in school cuz you're gonna
create [ __ ] like this yeah I kind of
want to kick his ass though Jimmy do you
want to bully him I don't want to bully
him he's trying to bully me he's giving
me a tall - man that I don't feel like
should be so I just wanna kick his ass
now he is throwing out of an alternator
he's like do you want to be [ __ ]
livestock or do you want to be a pet
that's like saying that there's gonna be
like genocide and like yeah during the
singularity event we are is it obviously
like it's something that has been talked
about before like Terminator was built
on that entire concept right this is
nerd rage yeah he didn't get with the
hottest girl in high school he got
picked on so now that he's successful
he's gonna use his nerd rage normal
people Joe he's listening right now he
has his ear do you dude
I don't care King got muscles look at
how [ __ ] skinny that falls off [ __ ]
his ass up that's why I don't Leslie
he's got endurance to that list of
people that are against machine oh [ __ ]
what makes him think that he's like the
all chosen [ __ ] the robots are like
you we'd like you give me that list this
fool is [ __ ] with my emotions right
now no I don't like this fool because
he's not he's not full religion he's not
full logic he's not float in between
this is like the scumbag that like when
Megatron comes down he's like I'm the
human that's gonna be your friend let's
wipe out all these other busy form [ __ ]
on [ __ ] 300 bucks in the Turk cease
[ __ ] sack of [ __ ] don't know who you
are shield with this shield
yup we're all [ __ ] up we just had this
whole episode right now it's going all
out we're all [ __ ] okay
I watched The Matrix and I know that
there's gonna be an eel and I kind of
feel like the chosen one so I don't give
a [ __ ]
me in that [ __ ] I will confuse
the computer because they don't know how
this works
shoot the beans don't even know how this
works the computer gonna go and say
doesn't follow logic don't understand
overload overload I'm a [ __ ] that [ __ ]
up I'm gonna go into the main server
where it all started in my brain I'm
gonna just [ __ ] unplug that [ __ ]
that's what I'm gonna do cuz that's what
we can do we could go to the [ __ ]
power source and unplug it and in the
[ __ ] computer can't live you should
start a religion bro oh but you know
what's gonna happen just like in the
matrix they're gonna humans that are
trying to blot out the Sun because that
was their main energy source and they're
gonna use all our energy yeah that's
what happened that sucks you know it's
so weird because it's like we're in this
era where people are trying to either go
super technological or people are trying
to reverse back and go back to more of
like a natural state that's me it's like
this this thing this one better than
this one I want to go back to like
imagine if we're all living in huts and
[ __ ] every day we just danced and
ate [ __ ] donkey and we just got a
barter trade [ __ ] you maybe monkey huh
you want to eat monkey over donkey yeah
because donkey is kind of weird like
those are what we ride in a while yeah
but we ride donkeys we eat monkeys the
world dude fishes in the equation I know
I was just imagining us being in the
Midwest or somewhere there's my I don't
know realistically I'd rather have a pet
than be a pet I'll say that yep sure so
if this guy thinks that like at the end
of the day [ __ ] I'd rather be a wild
animal and the robots don't even come
near me I feel like having a
conversation with this guy is gonna be
[ __ ] annoying yeah you know what I
mean or we all just submit and we're
like dude we're religious with you now
dude what if we get converted in we just
see [ __ ] and we're like oh my god he's
right it's just too long of a wait maybe
that's the problem too like I gotta wait
for that long I'm gonna run away to some
indigenous tribe somewhere and yet I see
signs of it fine I'll convert over last
year eating monkey
I'll be like welcome finally you guys
yes I'm coconut that would be the first
and I told you guys I don't know why
picture cast like Tom Hanks castaway but
Joe liked the way he looked
[Music]